montre-moi ton slip et je te dirai
quelle est la qualité de ta terre le
test du slip est un test très sérieux
mise au point au Canada pour évaluer la
capacité de décomposition du sol plus la
terre est vierge de produits
phytosanitaires par exemple plus le
tissu en coton bio se décompose
facilement après avoir passé plusieurs
semaines sous terre un test réalisé par
les élèves d'une classe de la MFR
val-de-mance à Noyant de Touraine
débrief en classe sur l'état de slip
enterré depuis février sur leur lieu de
stage
après 68 jours passés dans la terre ses
bouts de tissu sont parfois difficiles à
déterrer les élèves de cette classe de
première en conduite et gestion
d'exploitation agricoles viennent de
tenter cette expérience originale
enterré un slip en coton biologique
pendant deux mois puis observez son état
de décomposition et les organismes venus
le grignoter il y avait aucun nombril
mais il y avait des petits insectes il y
avait des fourmis au dessus les racines
étaient vraiment allées dans le slip
pensait qu'il allait être moins dégradé
parce que c'était une terre qui avait
pas été travaillé depuis longtemps et on
connaissait pas du tout la vie du sol la
vie du sol c'est ce que permet de
mesurer cette expérience voir
concrètement la capacité des
micro-organismes présents dans la terre
à dégrader de la matière organique en
seulement quelques semaines
mon slip c'est celui-là il a été enterré
le 22 février plus le slip est dégradé
meilleur est la vie microbienne du sol
les résidus de plantes après
une récolte elles vont mieux se dégrader
vont être beaucoup fin la vie du sol
tourne mieux quoi c'est pas un test
scientifique normé qui permet
immédiatement de tirer des conclusions
sur les pratiques de l'agriculteur ou
sur le ou sur les sols c'est plutôt un
test ludique qui vise justement à
sensibiliser à la vie microbiologie des
sols et dont les jeunes se souviendront
certainement pendant un moment qui peut
expliquer que il y a une partie qui est
effectivement à peine à peine dégradée
c'est peut-être ce tassement de ce
Tasman de sol résultat de l'expérience
enterrée dans des champs différents les
slips ne se sont pas tous dégradés à la
même vitesse type de sol pratique
agricole humidité ou tout simplement
manière dont a été enterré le slip les
facteurs explicatifs sont variés
c'est ce slip là qui remporte la palme
si vous souhaitez en savoir plus ces
slips seront exposés les 12 et 13 mai
lors des portes ouvertes de la MFR du
val-de-mance